So that brings us to this concept of
cache affinity scheduling. Basically, the idea is very, very
simple. And, and that is, if let's say, that
a particular process at P1. I had this thread
T1 running for a while and it got
descheduled at some point of time becuase it made
an I/O call, it tried to synchronizes another thread.
Whatever it is. Or time quantum. Expired for T1,
any of those situations will result in T1 one
getting descheduled, and then the schedule is going to
use the process of for, perhaps running some of
the thread, but finally, at some point of time,
if T1 gets ready to be scheduled again It makes a lot of sense for T1 to be
scheduled on the same processor. Why? Because it used
to run on, this processor P1 and therefore the,
the memory contents of T1, T1 that needed
to have its execution. We're in the cache
of P1, and therefore, when T1 gets ready to run again, if I schedule T1 on the
same processor, it is likely that T1 will
find its working set in the caches of P1.
That's the reason why it makes sense to
say well, look, let's look at the affinity Of
a particular threat to a processor. Cache affinity of
a particular threat to a processor. So, the cache affinity
for this thread is likely to be higher for
P1 because, it ran on P1 before, got descheduled and
is rescheduled on, when it is time to reschedule
it if you reschedule it on the same processor, good
chance that T1 will find its working set. In the
memory hierarchy, the caches of processor P1. But can something
go wrong? Well, what can go wrong is
the following. When T1 was descheduled, the scheduler may
have decided that, okay, P1 is now available for
doing business for some of the thread, so it
scheduled T2 and it scheduled T3 And eventually, when
T1 gets ready to run again, it's ready to
run again, but in between, it's running on the
processor here and running on the processor again here,
along this timeline. Two other intervening threads ran on
P1. So watch out. The cache may be polluted
by the contents of threads T2 and T3 So far as T1 is concerned. So, when T1 runs
again, it's quite possible that it may not find
a lot of its memory contents in the Cache
because these two guys that got in the middle
of its running on the process at T1 may have
polluted the cache and gotten rid of a lot of
this stuff that used to belong to T1, and therefore even
though we, we made this choice that, well, when T1
is ready to run, let's put it in on P1. But
it used to run before. And that way, we can
ensure that T1's working set, is probably in the cache of,
process of B1. But unfortunately, these intervening threads may have
polluted the cache. So that's something that you have to watch
out for. So the moral of the story is
that you want to exploit cache affinity. In scheduling threads
on processors. But also, you have to be worried about
any intervening threads that may have run on the same
processor and may have polluted the cache as a result.
So, that's something that you have to watch out for.
So, now that I've introduced the idea of cache affinity
for a processor,uh, we'll just pick to a particular thread,
we are now ready to discuss different scheduling
policies, that an operating system may choose to employ